welcome to the call today i want to open
the floor up
to ask you guys because i'm sure because
it's been it's been 30 days since last
time we spoke
so if you guys have questions in the
chat burning burning things decisions
that are impending
things you are unsure about strategies
that you need to validate or even just a
a verbal high five please put in the
chat
i'll go i'll go from top to bottom and
then we'll rock and roll from there
mr pittman question that leans on
philosophical meaning of lifestyle
what's
sure let's uh let's let's rock it let's
do it
so in your podcast you talk a lot about
the um
like how happiness is like the equation
of like
warrants versus needs and like i had a
million cash in the bank but i was
living off of
30 grand or something like that and so
like were you
have you always just been predisposed to
wanting
less or is that like a skill that you
learn because most people are like yo i
want to make
millions and millions of dollars so that
i can get more
at least that's kind of like where i was
the direction i was going until i like
started listening to you and now i'm
thinking like
um you know and so i'm just curious to
know like if that was just like a
natural like
predisposition that you had or you like
got to a certain point to where you're
like okay now that i've experienced
more i want less like how did that all
kind of play out because i think it
would help me become more happy
man that's a loaded question it has
probably been what that question
has been the the primary thing that's
occupied my myspace in the last
18 months and so for context i don't
talk as much publicly about what we do
but like between our all of the
companies that we own we're doing
just under two million a week like i
don't need to take these calls
right i do these things because like
they're the few things that i drive joy
from
like i love you know like i like hearing
peter's updates i like karen patrick
knowing that he's he's he's moving you
know for the chiropractor business and
jason's
finally getting his [ __ ] legion uh
is set up and mack you're doing your own
dance thing which is sick you know what
i mean and michael i know i remember
your first sale like
that that is where i find meaning and so
i think first off if you redefine the
term
from happiness which is which is based
on outside circumstances you are happy
as a reaction
joy comes from within which means that i
can be sad and sorrowful and filled with
joy
you can mourn and be joyful because
joyful as an ex is how you choose to
experience
the circumstances so first i would
redefine the word that you're shooting
for
right the second thing is
is asking like but why right and so a
lot of us want to make money
because we're like i want to you know
and and then and then when we talk
publicly it's like i want to leave a
legacy i want to leave an impact
blah blah blah right all that stuff i
want to help people
but the reality is that everything that
you do that is
external achievement is ephemeral and
what it means is it literally only
exists on the physical plane
and that physical claim is temporary
which means it will end which means that
all of the achievements and all the
things that you're doing on this plane
literally by definition will have no
lasting impact
and so if it means that nothing that you
do any all the things that you
accomplish
and all the things or rather the wealth
that you accumulate will eventually
disappear it changes the perspective
somewhat
and so the way that i like to think
about it is the analogy of a casino
and so i think all of us are given a
token when we're you know when we come
of age and
start to get into the game and we sit
down at a table and we play and we play
and we play and we play
and the players around the table are
bragging about how their how big their
chips are some players win
some players lose and more more chips
get stacked right
but the difference between that casino
and the casino of life is that
at the end of the day you leave the
table with your chips still
on it and you don't cash out and then
everyone takes the chips that you had
there
so you're playing a fake game with fake
money
and so i think when you realize that
like you can buy a castle you can buy a
house
and there's a person in india who has no
shoes
who has more joy in their life you
realize that none of the things that we
do to accomplish
serve any real meaning whatsoever they
really just act as the shovel that we
use
to dig the holes that we're going to
fill back
up at the end of the day when we die and
so it's like what shovel do you want to
use
to dig your hole and so
i like to think of those things as what
things do i
inherently find joy in
and so for me i enjoy learning
and i learn through teaching and so that
is how
i derive meaning and the only thing
that i can dedicate my life to that is
eternal
are things that will last past the
physical plane which
are values and so if you can shift your
decision-making process from
outcome-based decision-making process to
value-based decision-making process
you'll always feel
in alignment with your identity and so
for me when i experience alignment
between what i truly believe
what i say and what i do i feel like i'm
acting in the way that i
that is in alignment with who i am and
so i think that a lot of us have made
decisions or
say things that are contrary to what we
believe or we do things that are
contrary to what we say
we do things contrary to what we think
and we experience dissonance and that's
most of our lives
and so i think that if you can free
yourself into thinking i can
i believe these things to be true i say
them with certainty
and my life is a reflection of those
things which i believe
to be to be meaningful and i can
dedicate my life to that eternal value
and that value will exist after i die
and so that for me is is is kind of
where i derive meaning
from work
that was helpful um yeah i was real big
how have you defined your values though
you know like
did you like sit on a stone say like i
value
integrity and courage and like what does
what does that look like and how does
that play i mean obviously if you do
business you're doing it with
integrity and courage or whatever your
values are but like how do you make
if you think about it there's a lot of
times where
where we we sacrifice we cut a small
corner
right and so where we cut the small
corners a lot of times it's not
anything that anyone else would notice
it's just that we know it
like you make the email campaign and you
just know you didn't do your best
you just wanted to get it done right you
made the ad and you didn't really go
through the process that you
know you should be going through right
you made the the vsl and you just tried
to knock it out because it was on your
to-do list rather than thinking like i'm
going to make this truly excellent
and so every time you do that you live
outside of the values that you have for
yourself
and so i think that like you you feel
like you live in alignment when
what you say to others about what you
believe is actually what you do
and so yes sure we all believe in being
honest
sure we all believe in trying hard sure
we all believe in doing your best
but no one [ __ ] does
man i out work everyone was like go to
[ __ ] china
where they work six days a week 12 hours
a day
and that is their 40 hour work week and
tell me how hard you work
i work the weekend you're so hardcore
right and then why is working even
considered something that's laudable
right laudable like why is it why is
that even anything
because like we're supposed to be doing
things that we enjoy that we derive
meaning from
so why should we be louded for doing
things that we find joy like that we
derive joy from
just interesting thoughts but um anyways
michael that's
um that's my that's my two cents on it